they came back for VMAs together which
was like [__] viral the idea that
they finally it's got a baby yeah yeah
see I don't like that much but that's
Britney Spears no that's that's insane
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we are asking were you
team in sync or team Backstreet Boys
ah interesting
can I be I'll go after Joe
to be honest I don't know which song is
which bro me neither yeah see one song
that you think of something
my team at that time was team white
people or team black people and I was
team black people Boyz II Men any like
Kiss FM [__] like NSYNC [__]
whatever the Savage guard and all that
boy
okay don't do it on the topic don't do
bro get back to the white people okay I
I feel like
okay back then
everyone had radio or like you go to the
mall and like you're just kind of like
listening to the top 100 over and over
and over so even if you don't buy an
album for some reason if one of those
songs come up it's like you know a word
for word oh yeah
about It Backstreet Boys okay it was a
test for him he didn't know Ma you
obviously listen to white people my
heart these are like I even know the
[__] words right I guarantee you I
haven't even downloaded that in my Kaza
I haven't even saw I didn't even like
how do you
video of the two Asians it was like the
first one of the first YouTube videos of
a viral like two Asians lip syncing
that's all
it's probably these guys oh you haven't
it's not Wong Fu because David really
they did a lot of those completely
random Channel really yeah but it hit
like a hundred it was like one of the
most viral videos ever really funny
sounds familiar actually yeah
let's go back let's go back to the boy
band trivia can you sing another song
and see if Joe can guess it okay no you
sing it and then we'll see who guesses
it no I know you're gonna know because
you're a fan you're pretend you're not a
fan because you're a hardcore [__] but
you're a fan I'm not hardcore you like
Backstreet Boys I think
I think I like more Backstreet Boys in
sync because we recently all the news
was in sync Tiff she was a big fan she
was a major fan growing up so we started
watching all these songs and we started
doing comparisons between Nsync and
Backstreet Boys and to me I think
Backstreet Boys have the better bangers
now Backstreet Boys more memorable I'm
team basketballs as well but I hella
enjoyed it no definitely who's bigger in
sync bigger well JT went so far wait
which one is uh how which one was he in
and sing they they came back for VMAs
together which was like [__] viral
the idea that they finally it's got a
baby yeah yeah see I don't like that
much all right ready here we go but
that's Britney Spears no that's that's
insane 17 17 years ago 15 million views
you don't remember this video oh
[Music]
YouTube man holy [__] that's Hitman
breaker ERA this [__] that's Britney
Spears that's because of the way you
said it sounds like that she has a song
like that isn't that oh baby baby yeah
she talks like this guy that baby yeah
same song
stop dude looking back at it and you see
the whole era like they all talk like
that there's even beats that sound the
same damn
yell right
right
but that sounds like a [__] song
that's true
it's like it was for that time only and
everything after that it was a format
yeah it's so crazy to see how it evolved
you know my favorite Christmas song of
all time
Merry Christmas happy holidays oh
which one do you think has more bangers
than the other because I agree with Nick
I think back three boys what's another
Backstreet Boy Banger Show Me the
Meaning
bro because that was just like oh wait
that's not UB40 what though
now the Backstreet Boys saying red red
wine
that wasn't ocean
red
that was the same
as a beggar oh no I think Backstreet
Boys have the better songs overall I
think Justin Timberlake made NSYNC I
think without him don't you feel like
when NSYNC was like in their Prime
though it wasn't really about JT it was
only about like uh JC or whatever but
like now me now I can only remember JT
yeah from NC because he survived he was
The Mickey Mouse Club he was the most
marketable one but I I saw this one Tick
Tock video taking all of uh JC's like uh
breakdowns from all the songs and I
think he has the best vocals actually
yeah he was the main dude actually at
that he wasn't as marketable so he
wasn't with the front map when he hear
all the yeah yeah yeah in the back of
the songs is JC nailing them
um Tiff was uh she used to have a big
old crush on JC chassis or whatever his
name is yeah you know how to say it just
say it JC Shaz is it I don't know it's
not Chavez it's not I don't think it's
Chavez no I think it was the other dude
that's gay Lance oh oh yeah you saw
those videos you watched the music
videos in your life Lance Bass But if
there's one guy with a goatee I'm like I
don't even remember this [__] guy
Robert
Jimmy
what else Jimmy I believed you though I
want to go back to more things that Joe
remember yeah yeah yeah yeah let's sing
the song and see if he remembers he's
gonna be like uh Brian McKnight see it's
it's hard because I'm trying to remember
uh NC like I know the songs so if it
comes and plays I'm like oh yeah I
wouldn't know if it's NSYNC or
Backstreet yeah okay how about this song
what's the shape
I don't know this one
I don't know I don't know but I know
that part it's like that's no doubt yeah
yeah
we're only doing uh Backstreet Boys I
listen to the other ones uh we gotta we
gotta do it like it's [__] a heads up
we can only hum okay no no lyrics all
right
oh [__]
say the words
yeah I think I know huh he's like Bone
Thugs
It's gotta be in sync it's insane okay
well because they both could sound like
they is it like
Tearing Up My Heart very good job
Tearing Up My Heart but when you hear in
sync you get distinctly hear JT's voice
mostly because he had a giant massive
career after insane so it's like you
always know his voice yeah you're like a
little more biased to it yeah yeah like
you you're just you I really like this
voice because it was solely but people
do always say like JC Chavez is like the
main dude like he was he was definitely
dude who was the man dude
I that I don't know I I want to say it's
basically two guys I was having an
argument with somebody the other day and
I was like it's Nick Carter and I'll or
it's Aaron Carter but he's not here he's
not even in he's the brother who died
yeah rip well [__] but Backstreet Boys
see that means they're a better team if
you don't know who this is I feel like
it was
very much both Brian the the shorter
white dude with short hair with the with
the with the curls like this yeah they
were like glued on and then the other
one was AJ with the bad boy
right you know what I'm talking about
and he always had bandanas and [__]
right yeah he's like a biker I'm gonna
play the first like two seconds of the
song all right go
[Music]
oh wow
why'd you get Vietnamese
that's uh Backstreet there it is that's
Cisco
what's the name of this song as long as
you love me as long as you love me hey
you see this guy oh that's the first
song I sing no yeah dude that's number
two that's number two on there
yeah yeah yeah
by Britney Spears yeah what's everybody
oh everybody every is that what that
song was everybody body yeah
yeah [__] somebody yeah
back Streets back all right [__]
songs he's like that's NC
The Shape of My Heart
which one was that one the shape of my
heart that's Backstreet Boys okay play
another one
yeah two notes you know what though a
good pop song I feel like after you hear
it one time you know so many parts
that's like Taylor Swift bro when I
heard her catalog I was like that's
Taylor Swift so every time I hear
something she's thousands The Shake It
Off song as soon as I heard it one time
I Shake It Off I shake it off he just
takes one song to go all right it's in
my head now now in all the [__] words
perfectly crafted that's it that's why
Illuminati [__] music dude
brainwash you but even you know that one
song by Bruno
you just hear it one time in the store
you're like oh I know that song
here we go ready two seconds one second
oh oh that's Backstreet how do you know
what made you think that well you've
noticed do you know the song no I I feel
like it's back that's my best guess what
song is it
some [__] stupid song happy birthday
that's hard bro like one second
chorus
it's familiar though yeah but you know
it like that's the thing you really [__]
about it yeah
okay
that's Rocky I have a tiger
Pork Center yeah
that's great the other side is trans
holy [__] but like all that [__] is
ingrained in our brains like we will
never forget this that was so good we do
until we are slightly remembering labels
now or having all artists like remake uh
like I feel like right now we're in the
least creative time a lot of labels are
reusing the old songs because they have
it already stocked up yeah because they
bought rice to it so now like people are
like same thing with movies yeah movies
just all Marvel movies yeah this this
was a this is a this is a special one
you ready for this give us some deep
Cuts bro wait one more time who's
talking sorry
Nick heard it though
[Music]
I don't know that oh I'm just gonna
guess NSYNC just because you did
Backstreet last time but I have no idea
not that memorable dude not that
memorable
that's JT for sure right
you got it how's that how's it going
I don't know I just just start singing
It's like snapping into my in and out of
my head Play One More touches a little
bit more a little bit of the corners
ah I feel like it's one of those cute
ones no no the part another one
I don't remember that
that's the intro that's the intro here
I'll go a little farther with some words
he has the whole world
Colleen what team were you when you were
younger because you for sure were
obviously I don't feel like I was one or
the other I think but but I was both
same thing with like Britney Spears and
Christina Aguilera
nah no one says that about both of them
bro that was Christina all the way yeah
but then when Britney Spears came out
with toxic I was like oh yeah okay now
you got my attention that song is solid
you could be both yeah it could be both
Britney was pretty hot I I've never even
compared the two what how do you not
compare they marketed that way it was
like it was a baby back then guys I I
just I just think of them for such
different voices I guess it was like
Christina Brittany and Shakira
still got it VMAs so good it was really
good she got them hips yeah crazy
actually getting audited isn't she yeah
she's getting 100 for like four years or
something by Spain or whatever oh for
tax evasion or some sex evasion like
millions and millions of dollars damn
they should just let her have it dude
they need the money right yeah
it's her account's fault [__] you you
see Shakira seriously doing her taxes oh
it's not doing it off the Record thank
you yeah dude when he does the intro is
off the Record yeah I forget we have so
much fun I feel like that's the topic
wow that's very very smooth transition
as well that last song that was playing
this one
that was a core memory for me only
because that was the first song I slow
danced to in junior high wow do you guys
remember the first song you slow down
yeah do
the ghost town DJs um that's not even a
slow dance no no but that was the first
song in eighth grade when I had a crush
on Connie Connie yeah and I didn't know
if she was gonna like me better
you can't even slow down you can't slow
dance to that [__]
but that that song reminds me of eighth
grade this is my first no this is like
some news the new one the original
that's the OG Ghost Town DJ no that
one's the [__] the [__] the kids
the [__] doing this [__] there's the
original one
foreign
[Music]
ER Connie I Love You No sudden movements
[__] yeah anybody else first song you
got slow dancing damn I don't remember
dude I don't remember
any core memory eighth grade song there
were three songs that I remember slow
dancing to my first y'all remember all
three bro Middle School's hazy bro
really high school's hella hazy I don't
remember anything from middle school
like now I'm actually thinking about it
I'm like I don't you don't remember your
first dance it's because when he got his
first concussion they [__] knocked
the Middle School memories out of him
dude I don't even know where I am right
my three my three Middle School memory
songs is that one
Thong Song because I remember that was
[__] crazy like not our first time
seeing like all this neon [__] all over
the screen yeah and then oh
Casey
remember printing out the lyrics to that
because I wanted to memorize it yeah
I remember talking to like chicks on the
phone and you guys are just
the radio play
one better is like what what your
voicemail is
yeah I can't answer the phone right now
and then you record what's up Anthony
I'm not available right now check it
yeah yeah but not even like that it's
more like um
hey what's up you reach Anthony right
now and you're like 12 years old yeah
of course all my life was definitely
there at one point and I think uh one of
the songs another one of the songs that
I danced to uh in the slow dance was was
a Backstreet Boys song it was [__]
all I have to give that was your like if
I couldn't reach you this is what I'm
hearing
don't try on contacts but I also had an
older sister so I was subject to all of
my older sisters [__] because you know
she like dominated like all the radios
and everything like that so as a little
brother you just had to listen to
everything that's dope too though yeah
[__] what about you when you were in
middle school or your first dance my
first day I was trying to remember it
wasn't my first dance it was uh you're
like a little Uzi vert me and my girl we
we went to the same dance studio so we
actually had like a dance like duet
partner thing
you did a dance routine together yeah
probably sick you did a routine you
don't remember the song
I was just trying to fight my boner
then we had to tuck up at the dance oh
yeah
no I don't remember that it's a big
thing it happens it's it's a sign of
respect to be honest you got to think
about it like that it's respect because
there's the other option where you just
let them know it just points forward you
just let them know yeah it's not just a
little embarrassing yeah like 30 seconds
remember well if she's watching right
now you better apologize I'm sorry what
about eighth grade core memory song
what's your uh eighth grade core memory
the core memory I have was I didn't have
a partner for it because I was like any
song any song any song you're like oh
this takes me back in time I just
remember someone teaching me how to to
do the Spongebob
this one this is my first name
this and what song was that I don't know
what yeah oh I think it was uh
the Cat Daddy yeah
[__] different times
oh no copyright say something over it
this commentary is coming